voodoo
bea
me
ドロップアウトということでございます
特定の社会集団から脱落すること
完全に言うぞ
落ち込むんですいい
皆さんは落ちこぼれって聞くとはどんな人を想像する
勉強ができないとかに購入派集
持っていると犯罪犯して経営者にん
説明したや家族に迷惑をかけ
ここまでくると思う毎日狛江
外号です
今日は
そんなどうしようもない落ちこぼれた違う
新たに見出した人生
自分の命の使い方を発見することの価値について
暮らしをさせてくれ
ちょっと想像してみてほしいです
その落ちこぼれたちをどうしたら音声
ネジを締めるにはそのネジのサイズに合った動画です
ジャッジは車を持ち上げるためにあります
トラックを自分の力で持ち上げること思います
そういった仕事にはきちんとした道具があるんです
昔はよく売れているよう叩いて直してましたらこちらでお願いいたいします
僕たちは人生の中によくそういうことをします
僕思うんです
今の社会には人間の治し方としてい
テレビを叩いて直すみたいな発想しかないんじゃ
僕の仕事は四本松の回復支援です
これまでたくさんの人たちの回復し家族が笑顔に戻すも見てきましたん
彼らは第一級もスコールです
仕事が増えていて
酒房へよっても飲んでない
そういうんです
でもベッドんがから開幕日本中を登場したりします
そしてさっきも一緒にんだろう
糸を簡単に死んでいる
こういう人たちはどうすればいいと
刑務所が精神病院でも法力を向けばいいでしょうか
僕は重要性の時に覚せい剤を使っ
結果的に事務所になりました
やり方を教えてくれる人もいますがめちゃくちゃやり方を教えてくれる人はいません
でした
釣りがやめられないっ
友達が1人ずついなくなっています
系列される
はいレイアウト家系
知りたいと思うようになり
そしてみなさんにも依存症になって私が関係ないそんな風に思ってほしくないんです
自分の悲しみは不安味の感覚を麻痺させるための酒を売っ
ついつい自分のいらだちを子供にきつく当たることで
当たってしまう
ギャングやゲーム名 com
あなたやあなたの大切な人たちそんな日が来ないと言い切れるでしょ
なんでこんなことですよ
爆南じゅん
同棲を犬ができない
お前には多い
うるさいタウンあるん
皆さんをし溢れってどうやって作られご存じでしょうん
それは自分で自分に投げかける言葉です
自分には別名導線
自分なんか人に受けられないん
いつかないかに言われた言葉かもしれないけど今度はそれを自分で自分に言うように
なってしまった人が強くと思うんです
米がてぃぶな言葉を一日中趣味に向け
僕はそれを自分が作り出したストーリー
いつも自分の中で
意識に投げかけている言葉
そうして作られた自分のストーリーは
ランダーと周囲との関係を切っていきます
いくら仮面をつけて装ったとしても
自分の心に嘘はつきません
疲れ切って
き氷になると思う
うつになる人もいる
誰と心が通わなくなって暗い世界でだんだん一人クリーム
どうせ自分なんか愛され自分だっていない方がいいと思い
僕にも水よりストーリーになりました
アルコール映像ショー日
飲み歩く派
僕は暴力のある課税説明します
今日はから敵帰って来て佐々を7階が殴るんです
子供の世話もしないで何やっ
経過も理由あいつも僕でした
僕が寂しさや楽しみを表現することはハーフの立場を悪くすることだ
だから言葉なん
自分の大切な心
蓋をするような
たびたびなくなるんえっ
僕はカバをくれなきゃダメです
4割からこうなったり市街ねー
アリーのままじゃなく食べるんだ
必要になるんです
そう信じ凍ってしまったんだと思います
人にと言われたと思っ
始め覚せい剤を使った時のできて来ないような
それは自分に対する海
自分を責める声
壊れたテープで頭を持ったんです
ひと言で言う清寂
自分で自分のことを好きになりました
依存症はやがて進行していき
自分のここをどういうとおきたい
そしてしみたいと思う
こんな加工もことですが
今でも産後の友達が溢れてきています
1人始めた会社ですが
今ではスタッフが豪州になります
弟くらいとだった人たちが
自分をここで働きたいそう言ってくれるようになるといいですね
彼らは回復しろーぜーし結構
出産部分さえ到来しています
依存からこっちがあった人の中にまあ
愛車を起こし
独立する人さえいます
その中の一人
覚せい剤の内容と過食嘔吐が得られぬ20代のうちにされます
浮気を繰り返す父親
それをいます微笑もうとで
彼女あるでそこに以来子どものように存在してい
父上と母を読む気を惹こうと一生懸命やりましたがそれが叶うことはあります
あなたのお父さんは私に反して場名
違いが浮気相手からそう言われた日もいます
彼女はまだ小学系
中学生に上がると思う
なんで私を殺して障害
そういう風になってしまったです
そんな時に友達に褒められるのです
痩せたら可愛くなったねー
そう言われたとき彼女は自分自身のことを強く感じることができませんです
痩せた私は愛される
16歳の時
体重をに新3 k に向けしました
もう1人は男性の通りです
高校受験に失敗した彼はそれから17年間
父親をいつかこうしていく
そうい続けて1です
line をして怒れ父親だったのでいつしか父会うの同ロットメールっているように
なりました
父を言う通りにしたの高校受験に失敗した彼はそのまま家を飛び出した
そこで覚醒
にいただきます
戸籍上の名前を変える
犯罪に手を染めている
う序文入ります
2人とも愛のの十分には価値がないと送信して感じある自分になろうとしています
そうすれば家族とつながれると信じたからです
でも結果的にはどんどん愛の収録からも遠ざかってしまいました
ジョン松成信国の回復の精神北アメリカ
彼だから沢山のことができました
僕のメンターの一人でアングラいいというような映画シーンだとても大切なことを教え
てくれちゃうんです
それは価値ある自分を取り戻す方法です
僕たちはこれはで傷つけてしたいと思います
自分自身ギアス
1人大する
奪い訳してい
自分をよく見せたいという理由でついています
そういったことを一つの降らず紙に書きだして信頼の居室に履かせんですね
皆さんどうでしょう
皆さんの中に墓場に持っていきたいフルーツを持ちの方っているかもしれません
このプログラムの中ではそういうことも覚悟で終わります
僕たちの心がざわつきます
な事書いたらドウモウ
嫌われる
家だしてい
そんな葛藤を乗り越えながら書くことで
僕たちは色んなもの人名出合うことはないですよ
こんな私
それを朝
これが
私
今まで無視してきた自分自身を一つの躬恒耳を傾ける
それが勝つということです
こうして書き上げた私を人に話すこ
それは自分自身つながるという
僕は自分の話を16時間かけて
聞いてもらいました
これまで自分を避けてい
ドラッグやアルコールギャンブルとまで繋がってきた僕たちは
外尾何かではなく
自分自身をつながる必要があるんです
僕たちは本当にもう舌
次号施設
愛の方の自分を
このプログラムを通して私を殺して
そう言っていた彼女が回復することができました
今ではたくさんの初戦をサポート禁止テレビのコメンテーターとしても隠せません
高校試験に失敗した会は全国をというのを
行政の依存症対策を進めたいん
そんな6ね市議会議員の選挙に立候補する準備をしています
スタンプの50人スタッフの経営食事冒険数64年です
ひどい弊社です
でもそんな彼らは
今は講師として刑務順で向いているんです
依存症の回復プログラムを提供するぞメントっ
受給者の直接関わってるん
今では番号で呼ばれることはなくなる
エッセイと言われるように
これは僕らが新たに言い出した今ある命の使い方です
落ちこぼれも自分とつながることで自分の人生のストーリーを変えることができる
人が変われるんです
ある時泣いたりは今ここにつながるための招待状です
人間の心の健康の定義
それは
すべての感情を感じ表現できることです
つまりコップで蓋をしないという生き方です
それができれば自分への暴力人へのボールをうまくなるのです
つながりを感じること
それが人の心強く
だから一人じゃできないんです
できないようになってるんです
人はつながりを感じられないとつながりがないという
自分自身の人生の物語が開けなくなります
人間は唯一自ら命を絶つという選択肢さえ思っています
でも孤独に向けてもしれないんです
そんな時は正直さを持ってください
弱くたっていいんです
完璧じゃなくてもいい
ありのままへあっていいんです
高校受験に失敗した彼は実家に帰ることができまし
ドキドキし目から家に近づく
おばあちゃんからエンダーれたって歌っていてくれますよ
107年ぶりにか
お母さんはどうしようと小さくなっていました
お母さんとおばあちゃん人で炊き上げ
彼は自分自身ことを強く感じることがで
私を殺してそう言っていた彼女
お母さんにこう言いました
お母さんうん
私を産んでくれていい
皆さんはどんなストーリーの中で犬を美味しいと言えるでしょう
人間であれば誰しも
信じる力を持っている
肝心なことはその信じる力を
どんな風に使っているのかに気付くことです
みなさんは自分のことをどんな存在だと信じているでしょう
大切なことは自分自身ストーリ気づくことです
そしてそのストーリーはいつでも変えることができるということです
自分自身とつながってください
どんなことがあっても自分で自分の事を見捨てたりしないでください
だからこそ人とつながってください
僕はそう願っています
ありがとうございます
ああああああ